look at wicked Greg with John guys over
at patreon one of our reward tiers for
one of the higher ones is that whatever
video you request we must definitely do
there'll be a reaction or discussion
nine times out of ten that requests our
reaction so today it's from Kent
McKnight from Australia yeah Hugh
Jackman you dick mean Dundee Crocodile
Dundee trailer 100% through your nose
yeah there yeah we're gonna check out
the flying man today no so in our
patient we do fooled like TV show
reactions and music video reactions to
and weekly Q&A it's just self self shame
shameful plug self shame
[Music]
the orange redundant some people say the
experts who are analyzing the evidence
say this is clearly
[Music]
collision
[Music]
[Music]
oh this is scary
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you might still be alive to believe that
they [ __ ] there's one well you have time
buddy something my heart from alive
[Music]
they're at a drive-through
I've been there
[Music]
I like the gluten-free touch yeah that's
part tablet feels lived-in giving
criminals watched her way
everyone's particular
[Music]
he knows the woody Tucker who's lying
man
choose reserves I don't know you worry
too much he's only one guy can't catch
everyone careful
publish my sleep taking this too
seriously that meeting is blowing this
way out of proportion
he's already got one 35:35 yeah it'll
make you anxious we're not hurting
anyone Oh take it easy right
once we're done you know you take the
money they'll look after your family
land cheap flowers or whatever the hell
you want to do let's focus okay
[Music]
like for any crime thriller we're living
in a new time the offal on cap super
here of my it's like Neill Blomkamp
meets Michael Mann yeah I feel like this
guy wrote it the white guy didn't pay
for their drivers
[Music]
paper boy over here he's taking a leak
guys can take it down
[Music]
each time I take a little more
yeah guys I did just be fine I off
anything suspicious right yeah like the
sound
this is Hans everything
[Music]
do fly man's at picking life
[Music]
I need your fly see ya peaceful remember
these guys have very similar they
deliver in all their lives
[Music]
this was like shooting videos this guy
come on John watch the video mmm I know
if I can't
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
tracie visuals are gonna go down there
we go Wow
[Music]
[Music]
it's like a pitch for something feel
like
[Music]
kinda like Superman
[Music]
just and flying out the window
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
what dude it's probably I bet it's a
[ __ ] yeah like [ __ ] or something what
happens next
[Music]
cult music awake wait who directed it
okay so here's a visual effects guy
this is directing endeavor right here
there's stuff to appreciate about it I
like all the Neill Blomkamp stuff in the
beginning about the flying man like that
we don't know who the flying man is yeah
ever docu style it's very on the street
here a compiled video yeah and that
gives it a certain lived-in field I want
to see like a superhero movie where you
don't know who the superhero is I've
always wanted to see something like that
done I like that they're hinting at that
here that whole sort of he's the
boogeyman for criminals camping because
that makes the debate even bigger you
know when they try to do that with like
superhero films it's you really good or
bad like the way the public talks about
them I feel like that's more effective
if we don't actually know who in the
flying man if we don't know who it is
you do sit there going is he good or is
he bad I can't really quite tell like
he's taking out bad guys but there's
something kind of sinister about the way
he's approaching everything the way they
introduced him I thought was cool
because at first you're like oh this
guy's killing people yeah and then they
bring up the idea that they're all
convicted felons and then you know the
argument at least gets a bit more
complex but the first note you get of
the flying man is sinister I wish he
could just fly at a slower rate than I
could run none of the true benefits of
flying just just UK feeling it was that
was creepy when he when he's like just
picking them up and dropping them when
he dropped that yeah re yeah or yeah the
guy under the train yeah it does hurt
stuff like that is that
that's cool I like those visual touches
now in in real life I wonder if he might
have really destroyed that train
somebody directly under an oncoming
train I bet that thing would derail like
no yeah they tried like doing this whole
cool plot thing and setting up a
character what was the guy robbed his
name or Mike one of the two that did
that thing where they're trying to focus
on like the criminal plot world and
seemed like they were setting up as a
Mike the white guy I think so yeah when
you're kind of focused on yeah
like maybe there's some type of
partnership or bond that might form or
them I don't think the fly man just
kills him at the end well I took it as
he's gonna probably use him get into the
criminal underground even more be his
mole in a way they work together yeah I
feel like he gets the sense that this
guy wants to maybe leave this lifestyle
behind and even though he probably can't
fully maybe he can be like Mike Rowe or
something yeah I mean I just wish these
the writing of the dialogue and the
acting was better that's it in terms of
visual it's very much obvious this is a
visual effects director making a short
film so all that's cool even the tone is
cool and the style is cool it's just
really a performance and the dialogue
writing that felt hey you know student
film II and to me yeah I felt like
somebody's short I like the two of those
guys together even though yeah after a
few minutes there is a sort of rhythm
that you're like okay I could use some
maybe variety to the performances here
but yeah in in terms of the purpose of a
nine minute short you know I thought
they didn't mind together I didn't think
anything was hampered by the writing or
the acting you know it just wasn't quite
as on par with some of the really cool
visuals I wonder if they did a sequel to
this just act to the drowning man
drowning
one time superpower
yeah but I do like the concept I like
the way it's captured and then the
themes and stuff are better exhibited in
a format where you don't know who the
fly man is so I did like that mystery
intrigue so thanks for sending that our
way Kent it's a cool stylistic approach
to something we've seen a lot oh yeah
Kent listen buddy buddy buddy buddy
you've been one of our top pledges on
patreon for quite a while now I don't
know why you don't like
you know he's so busy this guy can
McKnight oh she's busy he said he says
we're trying to leave his job but they
won't let him quit we're gonna pay you
so much I don't like it here
10 million an hour whatever you want
how are your discussions going down
exactly I was like the last message you
sent me Kent has left his office like
I've been so busy to do a Google hangout
it's just I've been trying to leave what
they won't let me what does that mean
that you're trying to quit but they
won't like now once heard of that
scenario unless you're like
contractually obligated to like do a
performance or something you're such a
sweet guy we miss your smile you got to
get back on the Google Hangouts with us
man we miss your beautiful smile you're
erecting what rectum your rectum rectum
what word are you shyness or past the
yellow dollar bills oh I'm so rectum
all right ham rectum my rectum has a
boner a boner
mr. Boehner's Winter's Bone you can
subscribe to the reel rejects it'll be
it'll pays us five dollars every time
you subscribe it's the way it works and
we could use the money click that
notification bell we get an additional
five every time you click that
notification value to spits out money
they charge your card automatically
because in order to set up a YouTube
account to comment you have to submit a
debit card and also check out our
patreon that's free anything to get
actually dog you tweet opposite and
you'll have a good time there
take care